[Music]
[Music]
i'm a little late to the party on this
one but it has been a month since i
released a video so i'm a little out of
the routine but i wanted to make
something
finally after all this time the silence
from the developers of the division 2
has broken
on the 31st of march this tweet came out
today we have an important update from
the division 2 development team to share
with you it goes on to talk about season
9 the first season of year 4. and while
they aren't giving a date yet they
announced a pts for the update that
starts well now or a day or so ago to be
fair
if you weren't aware pts stands for
public test server the developers use
this as a way to test the updates before
anything goes live in the main game a
test version of the game
after receiving player feedback this
gives them the opportunity to tweak
adjust or fix anything that isn't
working as intended
given how long it's been i would say
that there will be a lot more people
jumping into this bts than normal
if you are wanting to give this a go you
can find the download in ubisoft connect
right below your games
unfortunately this is pc only due to the
limitations with xbox and sony and their
upload process
the pts is coming in three phases phase
one countdown and expertise phase two
new gear and balance adjustments phase
three
all of the above plus bug fixes
following phase one and two
currently we're in phase one playing
through the new game mode countdown and
trying out the new expertise leveling
system
i'm going to cover this a bit more in
another video where i'll give my
experience and thoughts that i should
have out in the next day or so
but i'll give you a little bit of a
rundown of what the game mode is all
about however some of the footage has
been played in the background right now
countdown is a new eight player pve in
game mode
two cells of four shd agents are
deployed at a power plant to prevent a
lockdown
there is a 15 minute timer that the
agents are working against where they
need to secure the site before it's too
late
when a couple of objectives have been
completed the agents can then extract
but this is where a familiar enemy makes
themselves known the hunters
while countdown is intended for eight
players and there is matchmaking you can
start with a smaller group and even run
it solo however there isn't any scaling
down for smaller teams you will still be
taking on the same difficulty and number
of enemies
i covered how expertise will work in a
previous video that i will link in the
description and it should be in the top
right of the screen right now
i'm pretty sure i get extra youtube
points for linking and referencing my
own videos so i'm just going to pat
myself in the back for that one
expertise is another progression system
outside of the shd levels and it also
provides a way to further customize your
builds for even greater build diversity
some may not think so but build
diversity is one of the key features of
the division that makes it unique i
would say that the bulk of you out there
who played this game for the most part
is because of the large number of
options you have when kitting out your
character otherwise you'd just be
playing any old third person shooter
like heartlands is unfortunately looking
like it could become even meta builds
can be counted you just need to think
outside of the box
basically anything that adds build
diversity is only a good thing for the
division
with the expertise system through
leveling the weapons and gear that you
use you can improve the performance of
select items
reading exactly what they stated this
feature is composed of two types of
progression systems the expertise level
and the proficiency rank
each eligible item has a proficiency
rank which can be increased either
through donations or kill xp
only when an item reaches the highest
proficiency rank possible will the agent
become proficient with it and be able to
increase the grade of the individual
items of that type
each type has the same amount of
proficiency ranks
additionally each agent has a unique
expertise level which increases as the
proficiency ranks are gained in more
item types
summing up weapons gear and skills now
have a new ranking system that we can
level up through using them in normal
gameplay
leveling up items will increase your
overall expertise level in turn granting
you something that you can use to
increase the base stats of an item of
your choosing
again check out my video i feel like i
explained it far more clearly
this update will also be coming with a
bunch of new gear and weapons
now i don't want to just sit here and
read from a page that i could just
direct you towards i don't think that's
why you're here but i will point out one
of the ones that intrigues me
catharsis exotic mask
talent vicious cycle
taking damage stacks to a cap of thirty
each stack gains one percent weapon
damage
taking damage at max stacks triggers a
purge removing all stacks and status
effects and then dropping a healing
cloud which restores five percent of max
armor for ten seconds to all allies in
the cloud
i can see this being potentially quite
useful especially with a new countdown
game mode
i'll post a link to all of the new gear
and weapons in the description however
if for some reason you did want to read
through them on a youtube video i'll
display them on screen now accompanied
by the sound of a young child playing a
recorder
[Music]
[Music]
be
as expected this update will also
feature a number of balancing and
gameplay adjustments
like the new gear and weapons you can
find a list of these using the same link
in the description but i would like to
point out that there has been a
considerable amount of focus on shields
the developers have recognized how
unbalanced they've been for quite some
time now and that they have been
considered a requirement in both pve and
pvp so the way some talents now interact
with shields like nsync and intimidate
have been considerably reduced or
removed a good move in my opinion
[Music]
it has been a long time since we've seen
any updates to the division so
regardless of what you think of what
i've just briefly run through this is a
good thing to see some love being put
into the game i will however say that
none of this is what makes me so excited
for the next 12 months it's not that i
haven't enjoyed what i've seen so far
but that there is more to the story
when i first heard that there is a new
game mode being created and some
adjustments and balancing going on it
didn't really fulfill me with hope that
the franchise i love had any future just
that it was getting a small update
however after yannick the creative
director of the division 2 posted this
up on twitter
yes i am just going to read this out
because i think it's important to hear
agents before we all jump on the pts
there's something i'd like you to keep
in mind
the year we've spent working on the game
in silence was not spent making one
gigantic comeback update it was spent
organizing and preparing for continuous
support of the game the importance of
this update is not in its size but in
heralding a return to normal with more
to come after that
if this update doesn't contain the
changes or content you're hoping for
just remember that there are more
updates coming throughout the year for
now i hope we can all share a happy
moment and rejoice that support for the
game is resuming we're live again
so this is potentially just the first of
many updates we'll be seeing as we know
support for the game was supposed to end
quite some time ago with no knowledge on
whether we'd be seeing any sort of
addition to the franchise
while i'm happy with what i'm seeing so
far from the pts continued support for
the foreseeable future is far greater
news to me
anyway i'm going to wrap this one up
apologies there's been such a drought
and uploads for me in the last month or
so real life has been throwing some very
interesting things my way as of recently
and i've struggled to find the time
but i plan on putting some extra effort
going forward i've really been missing
the creative outlet
so once again thank you very much for
watching if you made it this far and
i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Music]
oh